the east coast of the united states is
no stranger to extreme weather but this
is a winter storm of a strength way
beyond even what they're used to
times square in new york blanketed in
snow and treacherous conditions
stretching across 10 states up and down
the coast an area home to 75 million
people the mayor of new york out early
to record his own advice for residents
so be careful bundle up good day to stay
home if you don't have to go out
it is massachusetts being hit hardest
isolated areas expected to get up to
three feet of snow before this storm has
passed
couple that with wind gusts reaching
hurricane force in some places the
concern that blizzards could cause
white-out conditions and i want to make
sure everyone understands this even
though there might be a little break or
you start seeing a little clearing don't
be don't be misled by that there could
be a gust of wind that creates whiteout
conditions while you're out in the store
running to get that last gallon of milk
you want to get hopefully everybody gets
these in advance so this is not a time
to be out there shopping the stormers
hit air travel too at a deserted logan
airport in boston the departure board
telling the story of some of the
thousands of flights cancelled
it is areas closest to the coast that
are seeing some of the worst conditions
residents told to move to higher ground
with an expectation of severe flooding
for others there's little to do but wait
it out well how i'm gonna stay safe is
once we get home we wanna
stay in the house put our jammies on and
hot cocoa coffee watch some movies
relax and chill
they call these storms nor'easters
caused by what's known as a bomb cyclone
this is the first major blizzard to hit
the east coast for four years and one
they won't forget in a hurry greg milam
sky news